the daughter of the man described as
russian president putin's brain has been
killed in a suspected car bomb attack
near moscow now this unconfirmed video
is believed to show a distraught
alexander dugan at the site of the
explosion that killed his daughter daria
dugina the russian journalist strongly
backed the invasion of ukraine she's
seen here in a selfie in the ukrainian
city of mariopol after russia took
control of it her father is believed to
have been the real target of the bomb
alexander dugan is an ultra nationalist
whose ideas have underpinned vladimir
putin's rule
and for more we can cross straight to
dw's euro yuri rochetto who joins us now
from riga hi yuri what more can you tell
us about this incident
well according to the investigators
daria jogina died while driving her car
in the suburb of moscow
driving to moscow um dario duguna was a
prominent journalist in russia and an
outspoken supporter of what is in russia
called a special military operation in
ukraine there is unverified footage you
said it circulating on social media
which appears to show alexander dugan
her father arrive at the scene of the
blast
where his daughter was killed
dugan and his daughter were both
returning from an event they attended
outside of moscow reportedly mr dugan
made the decision to travel separately
from his daughter at the last minute
investigators say an explosive device
had been planted to the car so this
could mean that the bomb could have been
intended for alexander dugan because
daria dugan her daughter was actually
traveling with his vehicle
um can you explain to us who alexander
dugan the father of the kill journalist
is
well alexander dogen is a symbolic
figure in russian politics even though
he isn't a politician at all uh he's
actually a philosopher uh dugan is seen
as the kind of intellectual father of
vladimir putin's foreign policy and
especially of
putin's plans to expand russia and to
restore the russian empire
dugan developed
an extreme right-wing view of russia's
place in the world he stands for an
anti-western ultra-nationalist
philosophy and for a time at least he is
said to have had a big influence on the
russian president
yuri could would you say that this could
be seen as a sign a warning may be to
the kremlin
well incident like this as well as a
series of explosions on russian occupied
crimea and as well as in russian regions
near the border with ukraine undermine
the kremlin's narrative about security
and stability
why is this important well because
vladimir putin built his reputation on
security and stability after the
turbulent 1990s when car bombs were
commonplace commonplace in russia so
this is reasonably enough to make
officials in moscow nervous and
detention will now surely turn to who
was behind this attack and there have
been a few reactions already um denis
pushilin the head of the so-called
pro-russian donetsk people's republic
immediately blamed ukraine on his
telegram account
at the moment it's impossible to say who
is really behind these attacks because
we have no access to independently
verified information but it does seem
striking how the frequency of attacks on
russian territory has risen in recent
days
dw correspondent yuri rochetto thank you
so much